Good morning.
You're up so early.
What time did you sleep last night?
So this is a studio office.
All the extra desks are assigned to his assistants...
...who will be arriving later today.
He built this house about five years ago...
...and had this area designed specifically for his manga studio.
It's a bit nicer and more modern...
...compared to your stereotypical mangaka studio in Japan.
So he creates the manga called "Kanojo, Okarishimasu,"...
...which translates to "renting a girlfriend,"...
...a popular love comedy Rensai in the Japanese weekly Shonen magazine since 2017.
"Rensai" means it's been turned into a comic series...
...in partnership with a publisher.
Most of all, mangaka strive for Rensai status...
...as it signifies that the manga is popular enough for a weekly mass audience.